Free Speech used to be a left or liberal
value and and yet we see uh from you
know in quotes left uh a desire to
actually censor that that seems crazy I
mean I think we should be extremely
concerned about anything that uh
undermines the First Amendment there's a
reason for the First Amendment
um the first amendment is because people
came from countries where they could not
speak freely
and and where and where saying certain
things would get you thrown into prison
by the way in many parts of the world
including possible that people might
think are relatively similar to the
United States the the speech laws are
draconian is quite different I won't
name any countries but
um England why are we protecting them
they have no first in France I think if
you deny the Holocaust
which I think is abhorrent but I also
think it should be part of free speech
right you can be thrown into jail